foreign
[Music]
box today we're taking a look at the
Radeon RX 7900
XT and no you didn't watch this video
yesterday this is the XT version not the
XTX and our super dumb naming Choice
there by AMD which I'd probably go as
far to say is anti-consumer as Tim noted
in his rdna3 news video there are enough
numbers available so AMD could have
easily avoided having two different
products with almost identical names
there's really no excuse for this sort
of crap so do better AMD and with that
let's roll the ad spot today's sponsor
spot is brought to you by hetzner
hetzner is a leading hosting provider
and data center operator in Europe with
hundreds of thousands of servers in
operation by combining its strengths in
Innovative technology attractive prices
expert support and flexible customer
service hetzner expanded its Market both
within and outside Europe they operate
their very own high-tech data centers in
Germany and Finland hetzner also offers
high performance Cloud servers for an
amazing price and not only this hits the
is now already covering both the east
and west coast of the United States with
her latest location in Hillsborough
Oregon now you can deploy cloud service
in five different locations and benefit
from features like load balances block
storage and more so for more information
please check the link in the video
description
okay so the name sucks and I wasn't
Blown Away by the XTX version so is
there any hope for the XT
not really it's a hundred dollars
cheaper than the XTX so only a 10 saving
but the memory capacity cash and
bandwidth has all been reduced by 17 and
surprise surprise at 17 slower at 4K so
the cost per frame is actually worse
huh
well
I guess we'll continue with the review
anyway
so for those of you who haven't already
moved on to another video I guess I'll
tell you a bit more about the 7900 XT
before jumping to the benchmarks but
yeah I'm not going to drag this one out
the 7900 XT is clearly a product AMD
doesn't really want to sell suggesting
that they don't have that many defective
300 millimeter square gcds as noted in
the 7900 XTX review the XT version uses
the same die but with a one less MCD so
five rather than six and what this means
is any gcd that can't be sold as an XTX
gets binned as an XT so it would seem as
though the strategy right now is to cash
in on rdna3's hype try and sell the 7900
XT for top dollar and really AMD has
little to lose with this approach apart
from momentum market share and any kind
of relevancy with Gamers so yeah very
little oh and of course positive reviews
at 900 they can certainly forgo
reviewers getting excited about the 7900
XT so assuming this has little impact on
sales and general consumers buy this
product anyway AMD will have made the
right move
in reality the 700 XT is going to be a
model that moves in very low volumes and
again this could be due to the fact that
AMD has very little defective silicon
that they need to flog off but if that
isn't the case you can expect 7900 XTS
to drop in price before too long anyway
as you can probably tell I'm none too
excited about the 7900 XT so let's just
go over the test system specs and then
I'll show you some results now for our
benchmarks all gpus have been tested at
the official clock specifications so no
Factor overclocking the CPU used is the
ryzen 7 5800 X 3D with 32 gigabytes of
dual rank dual Channel ddr4 3200 cr14
memory on the MSI MPG x570s carbamax
Wi-Fi motherboard in total I've tested
16 games at 1440p and 4K so let's get
into the data
starting with the Callisto protocol we
see that at 1440p the 700 XT is 11
slower than the XTX and just five
percent slower than the RTX 4080 it's
also 35 faster than the 1600 XT a
two-year-old product that launched at
one thousand dollars US
the 4K margins are really much the same
the 7900 XT was 14 slower than the XTX
version though this time 11 slower than
the RTX 4080 the margin over the 6900 XT
also shrank to 28 so that's a bit
disappointing next up we have Forza
Horizon 5 and here the 7900 XT was just
nine percent slower than the XTX though
I suspect there is some kind of driver
related issue here as rdna 3 Performance
in general is very weak in this title
especially relative to what we see in
other titles when compared to rdna 2.
for example the 700 XTX was a mere five
percent faster than the 6900 XT and as a
consequence was actually slower than the
6950 XT
the 4K results are mildly improved here
the 7900 XT was 12 slower than the XTX
and rather than Trail the 6950 XT it's
two percent faster so yay
then moving on to Rainbow Six extraction
we see that the 7900 XT is good for 238
FPS on average making it 15 slower than
the 7900 XTX and 17 slower than the RTX
4080 while it was 28 faster than the old
6900 XT then at 4K the frame rate drops
to 119 FPS making the 7900 XT 17 slower
than the XTX version and 25 slow in the
RTX 4080 it was also just five percent
faster than the RTX 3090 but 35 faster
than the 6900 XT
the hunt Showdown performance overall is
very impressive with over 200 FPS but
relative to competing parts and previous
generation gpus it's nothing special
we're looking at an 18 deficit to the
7900 XTX while it was just 22 fast in
the 6900 XT the two-year-old product
that it's effectively replacing while
the XTX does that but with pricing so
similar you could say they both do
anyway at the 4K resolution the 7900 XT
fell well behind the XTX now trailing by
a 20 margin allowing it to only roughly
match the RTX 3090 while it was just 15
faster than the 6900 XT so overall quite
a disappointing result
like all radio and gpus the 7900 XT does
its best work in Call of Duty pumping
out 269 FPS in the Modern Warfare 2
title that made it 14 slower than the
XTX model but an impressive 23 faster
than the RTX 4080 and 40 faster than the
6900 XT so great results here though as
we found in the XTX review these results
are unfortunately outliers even at 4K
the 7900 XT was impressive with 163 FPS
on average making it 16 slower than the
XTX model but 14 faster than the RTX
4080 it was also 35 faster than the 600
XT which is a decent generational
Improvement
the f-122 results look very
disappointing as this game enables Ray
tracing by default when using the ultra
high quality preset and while rdna3 has
made great strides here there's still at
least a generation behind Nvidia when it
comes to RT performance as a result the
7900 XT was only able to match the 3080
TI and 3090 making it 11 slower than the
39 ATI and 15 slower than the 7900 XTX
even at 4K the margins are very similar
here the 7900 XT was again basically
only able to match the 3080 TI and 3090
making it 13 slower than the 3092i so a
very disappointing result here that's a
result of having rtfx enabled
the cyberpunk 2077 results are far more
impressive as for this testing we don't
have rtfx enabled in fact we're only
using the high quality preset and as a
result the 700 XT was good for 118 FPS
on average making it just 13 slower than
the XTX and a mere 8 slower than the RTX
4080 then at the 4K resolution we're
looking at roughly 60 FPS on average
without the aid of upscaling so that's
pretty good the 700 XT was 16 slower
than the XTX version though so given
it's only 10 cheaper that's not great
but when compared to the old 6900 XT we
are looking at a 31 performance uplift
as we found in the 7900 XTX review these
new rdna3 gpus don't perform
particularly well in Dying Light too
especially relative to previous
generation parts for example the 1700 XT
is just eight percent faster than the
6900 XT at 1440p and things are even
worse at 4K the 7900 XT was just six
percent faster than the 6900 XT matching
the 3090 TI with 60fps at average though
it was just 15 percent slower than the
RTX 4080 so when compared to current
generation Parts the results don't look
too bad but also not that impressive
when compared to the previous generation
models
the last game I'm going to look at the
individual results for is Halo infinite
so we're only going to take a look at
the results for 9 of the 16 games tested
before taking a look at the 16 game
average data at 1440p the 700x team
matched the RTX 390 TI making it just 12
faster than the 6900 XT
and then at 4K we're looking at 82 FPS
on average which meant the 7900 XT was
15 slower than the 7900 XTX and 20
slower than the RTX 4080.
okay so here's a look at the 16-game
average data at 1440p previously we
found that the 7900 XTX and RTX 4080
were neck and neck and here we see the
7900 XT is 13 slower on average which
isn't amazing given that it is only 10
cheaper than the XTX it's also just nine
percent faster than previous generation
Flagship Parts which probably seems okay
for 900 but given today's pricing that's
really not amazing
the 4K data is even worse as here all
other system limitations are basically
removed giving the high-end gpus a bit
more breathing room as a result the 7900
XTX is now on average 17 slower than the
XTX version and then when compared to
sensible previous generation options
such as the 6800 XT it was 34 faster and
while that might sound like a lot
remember the 6800 XT was released two
years ago now at 650 us making the 700
XT MSRP 38 higher and worse still the
6800 XT has been selling below MSRP for
most of the year
for those of you interested here's the
1080p data basically if you're playing
at lower resolutions or with lower
quality settings these new high-end gpus
aren't great in terms of value as frame
rate performance is almost always CPU
Limited
now here's a look at raytracing
performance at 1440p and really there
are no surprises here as the 700 XT
scales as expected relative to the XTX
model so whereas the 7900 XTX was 15
slower in f122 using the ultra quality
preset which does enable rtfx using FSR
to upscale saw very similar 14 margin
between the XT and XTX
the watchdog's legion results were also
as expected with rt disabled we were CPU
Limited at 1440p so the XT was just four
percent slower than the XTX but with rt
enabled it was 13 slower which is pretty
typical given what we've seen so far
Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy saw the
7900 XT Trail the XTX by an 11 margin
with Ray tracing enabled plus upscaling
and then 13 at the native resolution
with Ray tracing enabled so 84 FPS on
average made at 25 faster than the 6950
XT but 24 slower than the RTX 3090 TI
here we see when using fsr2 with Ray
tracing enabled that the 7900 XT was 18
slower than the xdx and then 15 slower
with upscaling disabled so again these
are margins that you'd expect to see
given the specifications and of course
everything that we've seen up until this
point and finally here's the sub hunt
2077 Ray tracing performance and at
1440p using the ultra effects the 7900
XT was good for just 35 FPS on average
or 59 FPS with FSR enabled making it 13
slower than the XTX model and a massive
29 slower than the RTX 39 ETI
on paper the 7900 XT is claimed to
consume 55 Watts or less than the XTX
and we're seeing pretty close to that
Nar total system testing I'm not going
to talk about all the data rather I'll
just show you the results on screen in
short the 700 XT lowered total system
usage by between 48 and 53 watts in our
testing when compared to the XTX model
so around a 9 to 12 reduction of total
system usage for a 13 to 17 decrease in
performance so even in terms of power
usage the 7900 XT isn't impressive of
course if we were to look at just GPU
power usage it would be more like a 15
reduction but still nothing amazing
then with the frame rate locked at 90
FPS and cyberpunk 2077 we see the 7900
XT drops total system consumption by
four percent when compared to the XTX
model so there is some power saving to
be had with fewer active cores and one
less MCD even at the same performance
Target
now while the 7900 XTX does represent
the best cost per frame ratio of any GPU
released in the last two years the
slightly cheaper 7900 XT doesn't in fact
we're looking at a rather large 8
increase in cost per frame for the XT
over the XTX meaning in terms of value
it's inferior to a number of previous
generation high-end products such as the
6800 XT it's also only a 13 discount
from the RTX 4080 which isn't good
enough given how much more well-rounded
the GeForce GPU is of course the real
issue for the 7900 XT is the XTX at just
a hundred dollars more there is simply
no reason to purchase this cheaper cut
down model you just buy the 7900 XTX
every time
and the 700 XT is even less impressive
we're looking at the current market
prices basically slotting it alongside
the 6900 XT and 6950 XT in terms of
value costing a little more for a little
more performance so rdna3 is hardly
retiring rdna2 there's really no need to
draw a comparison with competing in
video products either as the 700 XT
makes no sense at 900 or you can buy the
700 XTX for a thousand dollars
before wrapping up the testing here's a
quick look at thermal and clock behavior
of the AMD reference model installed
inside an ATX case in a 21 degree room
the Radeon rx700 XT peaked at a hot spot
temperature of 77 degrees after an hour
of gameplay with a peak average diet
temperature of 65 degrees and this was
achieved with a fan speed of 1750 RPM
the typical operating clock frequency
was 2055 megahertz and the memory
operated 19.9 gigabits per second so
just shy of the advertised 20 gigabits
per second overall the reference card
ran cool and relatively quiet so there's
that there's really not much to say
about this one basically there is no
reason to buy the Radeon RX 7900 XT
you'd always just spend 100 more to get
the XTX version and really for the XT to
make sense it needs to cost at least 200
US less than the XTX anything short of
that and again you might as well just
buy the fully fledged model
it's a shame that the 7900 XT would have
been something we could have recommended
at 800 at least short of a G-Force
competitor like the RTX 4070 instead the
XTX is a much better option and
unfortunately for AMD that means you
might as well just get the GeForce RTX
4080 or wait for a 4070 type competitor
it's a really weird situation where the
900 option is such poor value that you'd
really need to spend a thousand dollars
U.S but if you're going to spend such a
massive sum of money on a graphics card
you might as well dig deep for another
200 US and get the RTX 4080 for that
dlss support and vanc and vastly
Superior Ray tracing which kind of sucks
because as we've said the RTX 4080 well
it kind of sucks at 1200 us
but with the RTX 4080 at 1200 us and is
admittedly selling for a little over
that right now but with the MSRP at 1200
us the 700 XTX really needs to be 900
and the XT version no more than say 750
U.S
the only advantage of the 700 XT over a
part like the RTX 4080 is the vram
capacity but really the 16 gigabyte
capacity of the GeForce GPU should be
more than enough and I suspect it will
be for some time to come but of course
this will be a comparison that will
matter more for the lower end Ada
Lovelace gpus that are yet to be
released that said pricing for this
generation is a far bigger issue than
the memory capacity so while it's great
that this 700 XT packs 20 Gigabytes of
vram it by no means gets it across the
line in fact I've been so disappointed
with the 700 XT that I've requested all
aib Partners avoid sending me their
custom versions as I have very little
interest in covering them given that
they're just not worth recommending at
the current asking price
and with that I'm done with this review
if you enjoyed this one be sure to leave
a like you can subscribe there's a
subscribe button thing and we have float
playing patreon so if you want to become
a hardware box Community member you get
access to our exclusive Discord server
very cool place to hang out and chat
monthly live streams will be answer your
questions live so if you want to jump in
the chat and ask us anything we answer
those uh that's a lot of fun
behind the scenes content Q A's anyway
probably enough about this this video
um yeah it was a struggle to get through
this one very very boring product giving
the price uh yeah I want to get excited
about Harbor again come on guys like
anyway
thanks for watching I'm your host Steve
see you next time
[Music]